the Virginia State Republican Party is
calling for Virginia's Democrat governor
to step down not because of what he said
earlier in the week about what critics
called infanticide his description of a
bill about late term abortions but
instead about a new controversy bubbling
up late this afternoon a photo that has
surfaced from one of Governor Ralph
Northam 's yearbooks from medical school
the old photo getting a fresh look after
a newspaper discovered this racist
yearbook photo on Northam Spade picture
is from the 1984 Eastern Medical School
yearbook it's showing two men one in
blackface one in a Ku Klux Klan robe and
hood as you see here it's unclear who
the people in the costume are it is on
his page in addition the Democratic
Governors 1981 yearbook lists one of his
nicknames as [ __ ] man a derogatory term
reaction as you can imagine online was
swift and the controversy is actually
getting a lot more attention than his
defense a description of the late term
abortion bill did earlier this week the
governor's office has not responded to
the new reports Northam defended his
late term abortion descriptions today
hours before the yearbook photos
surfaced correspondent Peter Doocy is
following this breaking story really
just minutes before we got on set here
joins me now with reaction that this
picture is getting good good evening
Brett this page in North America school
yearbook is filled with photos of the
future governor and then there are these
two still unidentified people one of
them is in blackface one of them is in a
KKK hood and robe and now the Virginia
Republican Party Chairman says this
racism has no place in Virginia these
pictures are wholly inappropriate if
governor Northam appeared in blackface
or dressed in a KKK robe he should
resign immediately and the White House
Counsel Kelly and Conway sees now shades
of Brett Cavanaugh's confirmation
hearing where yearbooks were used to try
to back up unproven accusations she
tweeted this this should be easier work
than parsing every word and semicolon in
the Cavanaugh yearbook so Republicans
are turning up the heat on a governor
who was already feeling plenty after
explaining support for a
failed measure that would have permitted
what a lot of critics defined as
infanticide if a mother is in labor I
can tell you exactly what would happen
the infant would be delivered the infant
would be kept comfortable the infant
would be resuscitated if that's what the
mother and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue Northam ran a
competitive Democratic primary against
Tom Perry yellow and then a competitive
general election against Republican Ed
Gillespie but this is the first time
this year book page has surfaced in
public and I will just ask you at this I
mean you see online all of these people
who cover politics saying boy it's hard
to believe that either in the primary or
the general election that these things
weren't picked up I mean each one of
these teams has an apple research arm
and and today it has been easy to get
this your book page it's been as easy as
just calling the school and they're
sending it right off yeah it was right
there